👏👏👏👏
FINALLY
[I'm] playing a videogame everybody, hooray!
👏👏👏
Detroit: Become Human, the dumbest title ever. I can never remember it.
like Beyond Two Souls.
What the hell is that?
"Detroit:  Become Human"
Come up with a normal title, please.
I spent the last five minutes just being like:
'What, what was the name of the game again?'
Android whamen: Hello,
Felix: Oh God.
AW: Welcome to the Detroit experience.
Felix: *sound of disgust*
AW: I'm an Android and I'll be your hostess.
Felix: Oh, this is uncomfortable.
Hostess: Before we begin, let's make some adjustments to optimize your experience.
Felix: oof.
Hostess: These language settings were detected on your console,
Hostess: Are they correct?
Felix: Oh my god, She's breaking the fourth WAAALLLL!!
*Pewds laughs at his own joke*
Felix: Oh, that's awesome.
Felix: I'll do medium [text size]. I'm a medium kind of guy.
Felix: Man, It's weird.
Felix: It's weird when you see uhh...
Felix : You know [what], I won't go there.
*mad cackle*
Hostess: Please adjust your screen settings.
Felix: Okay they're fine.
Felix: They're fine. Trust me, they're fine.
Felix: Okay? Just--
Hostess: Thank you
Felix: You're welcome .
Hostess: Now select your profile.
Felix: What do you want- What profile??
Felix: Ex-- I want immersive game play... with advanced controls.
Felix: Uh, well, if you pick casual you shouldn't even be playing.
Felix: Here we go.
Hostess: When this sign is displayed, please do not turn off your console.
Felix (showing respecc): Well, you can't tell me what to do.
Hostess: You are now ready to begin DETROIT.
Felix: Thank you
Hostess: Remember:
Hostess: This is not just a story...
Hostess: /This/ is our future.
*Pewds giggles quietly*
Felix: Sure. SURE BUDDY.
Felix: Anyway, I'm really excited to play this game.
I love Heavy Rain, it's one of my favorite games.
Beyond Two Souls, you know,
it was entertaining but, no, it wasn't good.
So that's why I was kind of hesitant when this came out.
I didn't really want to check it out right away, until [the] reviews came in,
and then I just got off the hype train,
And everyone had already played it,
so I thought maybe I shouldn't play it,
but then I realized that it's actually really cool.
I, I want to play it. I genuinely want to play it.
So here we are. I hope you guys join me on this.... uhhh, journey,
It's always fun to do Let's Plays...
if it's a good game, and I'm told this is good.
Guy (relaying into walkie-talkie): Repeat, Negotiator on site.
And I'm walking everybody
Lady, in hysterics: No, stop... I... I... I can't leave her.
*giggles*
You hear stuff in the background.
HEY, lemme take this.
*Lady crying in the background*
For those of you who are not familiar with these type of games: They're always very story-oriented.
Uhh.. leaving you with random options in front of you
*Lady keeps crying in the background*
Heavy Rain was so revolutionary in the genre--
Lady: PLEASE,
Felix: I don't care about your girl!
Lady: Please, you gotta save my little girl--!
Let me go off on a monologue.
Lady: Wait...you're sending an android?
Police: Alright Ma'am. You need to go.
Lady: You can't... You do that! You woul--
Lady: Why aren't you sending a real person!?
Felix: Hey, I am a real person, thank you.
Lady: Don't let that thing near her!
Felix: Alright, Captain Allen.
Felix: "Consult your objectives". All right, what do we got- find Cap- It looks like he's--
Felix: What's going on here?
Felix: Hey bro, Android here. uwu uwu uwu
been ewwor in system
Felix: Hello?
*laughs at Negotiator being ignored(?)*
*chuckle*
Felix: Umm
Felix: I don't know [what to pick]. What's the name, I guess?
Felix: Uuuumm
How is he acting?
I don't know what's happening, so it's kinda hard to determine [what to choose].
So it was a hostage [situation].
Felix: Ohhhh, I see what's happening [here].
"Probability of Success" "Every Second Counts". WHAT?
"Understand What Happened"? Okay.
"Save Hostage at All Costs". I'll save the hostage.
"Understand what happened"?
Sorry. My objective is what?
Oh, it's all of these things? I thought I could pick.
This is really interesting
All right, analyze.
He's trying to.
Alright, what happened to you?
The first officer that responded.
Okay, we gotta find clues. Okay, that's cool.
Alright, what have we got?
Collecting data
P.O Deckart, Antony
Yeah, no one will care about anyone named Antony
*scoffs* What a loser
"Lead styphnate"
I'm joking. Stop crying.
"Only one shot" okay.
Alright *mumbling* need one more for the...
*gasp* Look! I found it guys. I must be some sort of detective.
All right, "right heart ventricle...". Okay, alright.
Lets DECONSTRUCT THIS, EVERYONE.
"Use L2 to rec--"
Okay, so we can see what happened. Ah, thats cool.
🎵Shot through the heart
And you're to blame, darling, you give love-🎵
🎵a bad name🎵
"Cop shot the deviant" "Rewind to search for a new clue"
Aaaaaand...
There was a hostage...
giving some moral support, got it. Okay.
And then, there must be another clue here somewhere.
Let's see, now
There it is.
I am G-. Honestly, I'm a genius. You're watching a genius let's play here everyone. You're welcome.
We found it. We found the gun. It's under the table
*broken laugh*
No one, thanks to hyper
*purr*
Technology
we managed to found the unfound weapon.
It's been here for years
No one could ever possibly have found it without me
Well, I guess I can't leave fingerprints if I'm gonna Android so I'll just go ahead and you want to stir that
one
Century, more Androids, less work
Connor, is that his name? He gives no fuAAH
That's close guys, don't worry YouTube bots aren't on us yet
Yes, I love this so far
Okay, so our probability of success increases the more information
Dude! You just..
Alright we found the hostage
Why does he kind of strangely look like me?
What's your name? I mean, my name is Con...
So I skipped two things nah fam
I'm playing this game wrong. I'll go back. I don't I'm yeah, okay, since I'm replaying this I might as well
let's say what I wanted to say, which is..
I love-
these type of games
Especially heavy rain. The reason why I heavy rain is one of my favourite games is because you truly felt like
You impacted the story with your decisions there's so many different endings in that game
and if you messed up the goal was to save your son right and if you messed up you could actually
It's such a dark ending and if you make it the game continues, I don't know
I thought it was brilliant and then beyond two souls games out
And the whole game basically just plays itself I think is an insult to video games
Almost in retrospect
but what I'm seeing so far is that this is actually they they've gone back to the rules
I love these type of games where you really feel. Okay, we're back. Okay, we're back
I was gonna say I love these type of games where
it really feels like
Your decision makes an impact but also it's hard to play for YouTube- Oh my god
Because people get so mad if they know you make the wrong mistake or the wrong move
I will tell you I will try my best to make the right decisions
But I hit that there's not family was about to have dinner
So we have two more things to do search the hostage room and examine the victims now we did that.
Probably if we go out like I did and we fail
The story will be different or they're just giving us BS and the story will go on no matter what the same way
That's the problem with these games. They a lot of it is just making
You think that you have a choice
I think that's why the telltale games got so stale is you play it the first time in your life and you're like,
Whoa!
I really feel like I'm making an impact on the story and I'm making my own decisions" and then you realize no
It's the same for everyone
Not a PlayStation VR Wow missed opportunity wait it's headphones. Oh the child didn't hear gunshots
Wait is it a meme? if you if you love the life you live you will live a life of
what that's the dumbest thing I ever heard
What's your watching are you buying on YouTube
I'm swiping on my thing. Zoella. No
Wow, Daniel you don't seem so cool now
Conveniently have that video played
I don't buy this this is too eyy our probability of success has increased. Alright
Examine the victims. Who's the victims? Ah, here's the victim
How you doing? Not so good? I don't know why I asked ok. So- oh an eye
Audience
Okay, same same mean different guy
All right along aroma ex who doesn't I wanted those what a crybaby
What an absolutely okay. I know he's dead. Where am I supposed to look at
Where must be on his face must be his hair
Ah, it was his titty I knew it
Yes best let's play on YouTube everyone
Okay, what did we get he was just sitting chillin he was holding something
All right, interesting. Very interesting. What else did we got? Oh
My god
A guy just shot him. That's not
nice.
*Giggle*
What does that mean? Okay, we analyzed everything oh
He dropped us something. you mean them.You-
Are you kidding me?
You could have just found that without all the..oh..
Oh yeah.. you got a.. Nice.
Aw. He was about to get replaced!
You son of a gun? How could you?
All right, so we still only have
76..
70..
Percent uh, what is the flow chart?
Oh..What? So we missed some stuff.
Talk to Captain Alan...
Whaat?
wHaAt?
No..
Thats...
Okay, so... locate the hostage it's the only thing left
Okay, there's here.. The gun. All right so we know we...
Well, we already found the gun.
What else could there be...
Huh..Bullets.
Okay, so there is more
The Deviant took the father's gun, okay
So we know he's armed basically.
78 Still?
Wuat the Friak?
I guess there is still some chance.
*Gasp*
EVery second counts!
I gotta hurry!
*Chuckles* Noo..
Okay.. I think we officially did everything
We have no choice at this point, okay?
Come on 78% Those are good odds.
Why would you shoot me? I dubbed nothing
Dan: Don't come any closer or I'll jump
He would never hurt her
Con: Hi Daniel
Oh, oh
Yass
*disappointed* uhh..
Come on, guys. You totally ruin it
Okay, we found him
Approach slowly. Okay. All right Daniel come
Then let the girl go Daniel.
Uhh
Lie
Damn it
"Emma and you", yeah, let's do that.
Con: You think she betrayed you but she's done nothing wrong
Dan: She lied to me!
Did you lie Emma?
Angst Dan: She's just like all the others humans
Aw come on Daniel, you're being a total part of your brain. What's possible cause
All right. Let's do that.
Con: That's what happened
He thought it was part of his family
There's something in the pool.
Dan:  But I was just there toy.. something you throw away when you're done
Sympathetic
Con: Listen, I know it's not your fault
Con: These emotions you're feeling are just errors in your software
Oh, it's going up we're doing good
*high pitch* hEcK yeAH
You're being a total crybaby
Dan: I can't stand that noise anymore
Top Dan: Tell that helicopter to get out of here
Ohh..
Okay accept
*Chuckles* No..No it isn't.
*LOLs*
Le oh, that's ...
Come on, last chance.
Aww damn it. Come on. I'm just trying to push a little bit
*Mocks* EmMI nIMe
*saliva noises*
No,..no fam.
Okay..*chuckes* you know what?
Intimidate
*Grunty Laugh*
*Mob boss voice* Yueah wut naow-ha-ha
Ey come on man come on
Whoa, what what what? Oh
No
Are you kidding me?
did I? You're being a total doofus
Oh my god
Dammit!
I am so pissed
There you go
There you go. Okay, so there are
one two three four
five
Maybe even six if I use the gun that was another option, I guess to shoot him. That is so cool that they show you
See this is what I mean now, I actually feel like
Aah
I wasted too much time apparently. Oh my god. This is so cool
Can I go back though, that's the real question. I don't think I can.
Ok, leave the gun.
Sorry, I
thought I could play it cool guess not
Come on
You're not going to die we're just going to talk
YAASSSS
Trust me. Okay. I trust you
Don't make don't shoot me in the face, please
Yeah
That's what you get Daniel, oh my god, this is Mortal Kombat scene, yeah
Okay, we did it guys we did it finally it took a while.
You son of a......
I mean..ehya
You shot me technically you shot me okay, so I don't know what to tell you
Connor gives the fattest dab right now. No
Mission success. Yes
Pretty cool seems really promising so far
What are you guys think smash like everybody smash like
Wait
Wait, what did I just play that without saving?
No, no, no, no. No, are you kidding me? I can't I cannot
Okay, I gotta pee. all right, we're back everybody yay, we're gonna play more
*wOW*
That took me a lot longer than probably what the video is
All right, who is this annoying little prick I can already tell
Ten thousand different dishes, what is this machine?
I'm sorry. Tell me more about this. Oh the part that an Android. Oh
Am I one of the showcases oh I am arn"t I
That's awesome
Are we gonna come up next to me? Just this one gives amazing handjob
At night
Contacts emergency services it was breaking or if it detects smoke. I mean, that's pretty awesome
Does that one know all the fortnight dances
Oh really can you do the L Danes?
Absolutely me anytime anywhere else Oh God. Don't buy me difficult getting it back in working order
It was really I'm repaired
A car hit it
stupid accident
I see
Anyway, it's as good as new now, except that we had to reset it. Meaning we had to wipe its memory
Hope you don't mind. I'll be fine. Damn. I don't know what's gonna add you give it a name my daughter did
We bought home register your name movie' my home
Dammit I'm a lady My name is Kara
Kara
So innocent so sweet. Oh
my god
This is a cover of
It's a movie soundtrack, so I don't know if David cage still work on this it's not his name David cage
He's like the first
Game developer that really tried to make games into movies you play one of his first games actually, it's the second one
What is it called comments? Help me out. I forgot
(Fahrenheit)
And I remember you play it and it just says play movie and rewind and all that stuff. That was a fun game actually
You guys remember that did you watch me play that game? That was a long time ago. That was really fun
Hey, it's come a long way since then it's pretty impressive to see that development how these games improved throughout
It seems also like they learned from
The last one which wasn't bad it just bad ideas
They desperately wanted to be a movie so bad
I think there was the first game that they beyond two souls was the first one the last one
That they showed it like a movie festival can movie festival or something like that?
If you guys had an Android what would you do it with it?
It's kind of weird cuz like if you play with VR and you see
Other enemies or people
It's so fun to just mess around with and I feel like if there was an Android you do the same thing
Okay, it's David Cage still working on it. Of course he is
Another thing about this game is that they always just look incredible and then we got a really ugly shot about tree great
Just the faces the way they did faces. I
remember playing heavy rain
before I did youtube I
Spent my last bit of money on that game. I bought a PlayStation 3 and
Heavy rain and it was such I had such a blast
It was at a time where I didn't really know what I was doing with my life. I
Was such a good escapism
All right, we're playing as this guy now, I don't know why
Sorry, I love talking about myself. What do you want I
have no objectives retrieve order 66 I
Have to go to Bellini PaintShop
Okay
So he is just sending out its Androids to do his errands this is so cool
Plastic idiots
We solve racism by adding androids now you can hate them instead, press r2 to use GPS. All right
Bellini Paints, not this way. All right this way everybody
Hot dogs, all right, you're doing a terrible job for an Android
Open your eyes
Boy
Can't swear just empty since let's check it out here
Demon oh really?
Where is the dab option come on
Right, I forgot we're in Detroit
He's the guy on the cover, isn't he?
Guess there is a thing with the slaves and the black men, maybe they'll play into that I don't know
Okay, so where is the stupid paint shop there it is right there Bellini Paints
color since 2009 a very good
Herrow, give me your finest paint, please
Identification verified. Oh, he's an Android too. This should be awkward
Here is your order number eight four seven
Please confirm payment.
Hey, it's the cover everyone of the game payment confirmed
Transaction complete
Obviously you guys probably heard that you can put like a chip in in your hand and then in some places very few
I think you can pay using the chip
Controls are still awkward as ever would you guys ever do with that consider doing something like that?
You know things that seems crazy now might be perfectly fine in the future
It's fun paying for stuff so awkward already like put in the card putting the pen awkwardly awkwardly waiting
Any time
I'am waiting to pay something and you wait for the machine, right?
I'm always considering like doing small talk or do I just blankly stare at this machinery?
It's my dilemma every single time. What do you guys do? Please? Let me know. I genuinely wanna know
Cuz it's so awkward right? It's like just too much time not to talk
No, the opposite of what I said and just enough time that you could talk
No one cares I get it
Why do you hate me?
I mean, they're literally everywhere. I don't know why hey
Hey, hey, oh my god. Don't swear, please
They terk our debs
Come on does he not know kung fu come on Neo download some moves.
You job stealer
All right
It's enough it alone. Let us teach this bastard a lesson
Hey, hey, yeah, I'm gonna have to fine you
Damage it huh. They're gonna take your job next.They took our job
Let's go
It sounds like you don't even need a job if you got another guy just doing everything for you get androids, right?
And then just make them do your job and you get a commission for it. Great
Alright oh
I gotta get the bus
you know people always get mad at
Destructive technology at least people jobless and it's understandable
But those those technologies bring in more jobs anyway it's always a cycle that we know has gone through
It's like wheat farming back in the day when they got machinery for farming
Oh they get to their it come on that has to be some sort of Rosa Park thing
They get to ride at their special place in the bus
Well, that was pretty pointless
Okay, wait, so
Yeah, it couldn't have gone different ways, but we could have explored more I guess so
Let's Marcus took the bus everybody
Interesting. Oh, this reminds me heavy rain so much
I you know what?
Maybe you guys are judging this guy. I'm sure he's a wonderful guy. I'm sure he's gonna take great care of us
I feel really excited about this. How can he afford her though?
Im baack
use r1 to switch camera angle
So awkward if you have to move your
Movement stick everyone. Hello. I'm a gamer epic gamer here. two weeks. So the place is a mess
Not my fault washing you cook the meals and you take care of
Swearing! Stop it.
That's Alice look after her homework bath all that crap
Got it. Yes Todd
Get started down here. Then you do upstairs. I
Really hope there's not gonna be any sexual favors, please
Hold r2 to scan the environment. Okay. So alright we're gonna clean that. Oh thank god game now. This is a game
Alright a whamen simulation
I'm joking
Okay, collect the trash
Kitchen, alright, what do we get? I could just gotta take you don't start by taking the trash out you damn big old dingus
What do I do now? How do I put it down?
Yeah, okay okay
Yeah, yeah I can get that all right, all right clean the counter
Where its oh
You nasty boy you nasty you dirty
Disgust, oh she just throw away the plates didn't she, look at that
Why wash the plates when you can dab on the plates clean the coffee table
Excuse me herrow. T.V. on
This guy eats a lot of pizza
How does she fit all those pizza cartons in that trash bag? Huh? What is this magical?
Cardboard Plus you can't mix. Oh, okay. She has two bags. Thank God about the future
A credit card application form. All right, and the bank is not doing
You know, it was me if I had papers like that I probably would have oh this is awkward
The thing with control your walking this direction and then all of a sudden you're walking the opposite and then you start walking
Whatever. I know you don't care
Oh, yeah Detroit had all these really bad neighborhood it does something doesn't, they do they?
I know that movie um
We have to be quiet with a blind guy
Reminds me this house reminds me of that one. You're welcome. Everyone. Yes for being so articulate
The TV dumbass, what do you think?
Hey you get that get the fuck out here. Oh, I'm sorry. I like hockey. Is that a problem?
He has a curved screen Wow
Alright, let's talk to her
Alright, let's not talk to her Jesus. What else do we gotta clean?
report to Todd
Collect the dishes activate the vacuum
option(optional) tasks!
Of course, we're gonna vacuum. What do you think? This is some game? Nah, I care about cleaning
What is he doing Oh
What is that sound
What is wrong with you? I think some weird drugs
I've made a good start down here. I'll head upstairs do what you have to do, but stop bothering me
Bibidibap skippity skoo. I love cleaning for you Oh Todd Todd is the best
Let's go upstairs everyone
Can I not clean those up that looks like
So, can you stop making that sound?
All right. Let's make the bed
ventilate the room
So this is why you tune in for this let's play to watch someone clean in a video game
It doesn't get better than this. Oh
Man, she's really good at making bed. See this is my dream. I hate making the bed
It's like one of those things. I hate the most if my sheet isn't perfectly straight. I can't sleep
So I have to adjust it all the time. I hate it. Okay, why can't we invent better sheets, please?
someone get on that or Androids I
mean not by an Android
Yes, I was feel so weird about
Like I don't like having a cleaning lady or something like that or cleaning man. If that's the case I
Just don't like having other people do stuff for me
But I was like Machinery doing stuff for me
Like I don't know why like just dishwasher in general makes me happy. I'm like, this is so great. I
Don't care about this, how do I get out?
Like have you ever tried 3d printer it always so fun lookin at it works
Why would I Switch it on
They really like yellow on this channel
So there is a thing about rights between Androids and Humans
That's interesting
Another 225 jobs?
Alright, We get it it's a lot of controversy we gotta ventilate as well that is definitely what I wanted to click
Man I feel like cleaning in real life now
Alright what is this?
What is this?
Is that me?
That must have been
Okay, Todd's room check
We've done it all.
Wha?
I love Todd that's so Todd. I love Todd he's so great
Ahh the toilets stuck with Todd's poopy. Hey Todd is just the best. I love Todd
Ugh
Optional heck yeah, we're gonna do the optional tasks?
are you kidding me?
There's options for me to clean?
I just want to tidy up your room
I only need two minutes. Is that okay Alice? Damn? I that's right. I'm so good at cleaning
Can't you teach your kids to do this for theirselves? dumbass
Hey Alice clean your room you doofus there you get to do the shake
What is that that unlocked something in the future I'm gonna escape right
Hello, Arice(Alice)
Factual friendly diplomatic friendly
-Im sure we used to be friends before I was reset. Maybe we can be friends again
Um what do you like?
-You should tell me about yourself
What you like to do where you like to go your favorite foods, that would really help me
Tehe, awkward
Ugh Mother? -What about your mother?
Will she be home soon?
My name is Kara.
-Your father said you chose my name Kara, it's nice. How did you choose it?
We're good move here
What she gave me? is it a note? it's a key
Where does it go?
Kara's like, I love keys
I just love keys
Ask Todd. Oh, okay. So that's like all our memories
Jacksepticeye, I knew he was behind this after all that son of a gun
That's the mom? that supposed to be him he looked a lot nicer
And
She got a little bit of paint on her head
and then
Daddy wore a tracksuit and no one was happy about it
And then daddy
Had it
Hey, I lost my arm? Oh my god
Alright let's put it back
I wasn't hit by a car. I knew it
Alice in wonderlaaand
it was written by an author in Brighton I think, someone told me I don't know if it's true. I rib in Brighton
there's a lot of like, I don't know if this is true, but there's a lot of
people someone built it like a tunnel to the beach and
I don't know if it's true. It sounds like a lie, the more I think about it. I'm like that tunnel was
Inspired Alice, I don't know clean bathroom.
I mean we've done this much might as well and I'm sure you love hearing me talk about some gibberish
So why the heck not there you go shampoo tidy
Then the more I think about it you don't need an Android really you just need a woman I'm joking. It was a joke
That's a tiny ass mop that's not gonna
My god, this is so awkward
Why is it.. what are you?
Oh, I have to constantly rub it
OK we've dabbed on all the germs
It says it's time to move on Felix. Okay my god
Just trying to make the most out of the game I'm truly enjoying it. It's really fun.
Yeah, what do you think I'm doing
Yeah. Yeah.
yes
Well, you can afford the Android.
♪ I love Todd, Todd's the best ♪
Where's the dab button
If there's not one moment in this game where there will be a moment to dab
I'm going to be so disappointed. Here we go. Oh, look at that I missed one. No
No, damn it
Grr I'm so angrry
All right, let's keep playing we'll do one more we'll do one more. Okay one more one more come on come on
7:00 a.m. It's not even waking up in the morning
Cyberlife created by Mark Zuckerberg
Whoa
What if you were so rich you can you just have an army of androids that was so epic
And then you can fight them like Pokemon
That would be so awesome
That is so awkward
See if you could invent Androids surely you could invent pokemon
Carl I bet Carl is gonna be a total doofus any rich kid is a total doofus
What is this on the wall? Oh, it's one of those elevators
Doofus
Where is my doofus? "Wake up Carl upstairs" I am upstairs, aren't I?
Hey an ancient fossil in your home just like everyone has
WHOA Sliding doors, epic!
Is Carl...old?
*gasp* Carl is OLD
And he's got tattoos.
You don't forget?
Oh my god, that's what I said
So when is the painting meme coming because I feel like once once we've done that we can finish the let's play right
That's the reason
Carl!
It's the first one that's nice too an Android so far. This is so nice.
I misjudged Carl I feel terrible.
uh-oh
Please don't make me do that
Have you guys seen the movie "her" it's a really good movie about the relationship between humans and
I Guess artificial intelligence or AI or Android. I wonder if there will be like close relationships in
the game
Like that
that is an ugly cat
What is this move I have to
It's got a good atmosphere this game as well
I Don't like Carl's art
Just gonna say it right now
Do we put him on the elevator now?
Or, do we get the option to push him down?
That's so cool.
Whoa it's so fast
He's faster than I am. I want one [chuckles]
Okay, do I do I push you again yeah cool I teleport behind that's always nice
Sliding doors
Whoa. What a cool TV
Well, you're welcome
That's what I said
Okay oh are we making them?
breakfast, or??
Don't know how to make
Scrambled eggs, I don't like eggs.
I already made it. Thank God. whew
I'm sure the game would have completely ruined me
Okay, what's up with the mug
It's that from his kid or something
He has one of those water on the wall things. That's how you know you're rich
Et voila!
If he's unhealthy, is it really a good idea to give him bacon and egg when you're this old? just a question
Okay, just have some porridge. some good old porridge. delicious
Makes you poop right after it's great
Eat the fruits Carl
That's a two-sided television that's epic
something to do [chuckles] what am I gonna do?
In the other games there was like internal dialogues when you were lost.. I guess they don't have it
North Pole why Russia wants it
We need dominance in space
life found on Titan
alien life
Where are you going with this?
What is Titan
That's pretty cool
damn
mankind is so depressing
Well, I guess nothing change in the future
Wait
What year is it?
My man, on that whiskey
Is that's supposed to be- no, it's just fakes ones. I thought maybe they would do some parody ones
Like in anime
Alright, let's play the perfect piano then
Des-
Pa-
Cito
pere pere pere pere pe pe reepo
Melancholic hopeful intimate. Well, he's feeling a little
Let's give him some hope, you know
I'm playing this by the way by clicking there
You like this?
Alright you get the gist--did you like it?
Hahahahaha
*meme review*
All right, let's go to the studio... the meme is coming
Yaass
Why is those stairs, is that a giraffe?
Sure, why not
Why not? Why not?
Oh my god can't wait I'm finally going to see what the painting is
After all this time
What in the world is happening now
Am I supposed to do it
Okay, well that's pretty
Oh we got to clean the studio while he..
This is so cool.
Okay, that's terrible
What do I clean then?
Okay, what else?
really fun cleaning simulator I really really really enjoy it
Please please give me more options to clean
High five, god, I don't care give me something to clean
"Give me something to clean" words I never thought I would say hey
Have I done cleaning for you yet?
Give me the meme give me the meme give me the meme give me the meme (meme review 👏👏)
YES!
Are you tell me you never check before
Hmm. Hmm. I'm so curious what it's gonna be
All right
Find a subject based on like what I
What can I just paint whatever I want?
Paint Carl's painting. That's kind of weird
The desk looks more
Hmm uninteresting, let's paint statue. Oh we get to do it squibble squibble
This is how painting works in case you never painted this is exactly I'm finally a game why aren't you swiping?
That's true to the art of painting oh
Oh my god
Let's see, let's see
This one's bigger
Here it is, I'm so ready
I still get to pick I
Want to see how he looks at Androids
With hope
I really hope I Wow him
Come on
Who's this doofus
Language Leo, Please!
dab. dab. dab. dab. damn it
Okay, guys that will be it for the first episode
Loved it that was so fun. Hope you guys enjoyed us
Well if you did make it to the end
Please make sure you drop a like I would very very very very much appreciate that and I'll see you tomorrow with the next one bye